uluslararası pazarlamada ürün ve marka
stratejilerine yön veren ve literatüre
globalizasyon rehberi olarak giren kanun
modeli anlatacağım
bugüne konusu
uluslararası pazarlamanın yeni çağına
Hoş geldiniz diyorum Bu gördüğünüz
rini ama bugün
meditasyon kavramı
benim profilizasyon nedir globalizasyon
ve lokalizasyonun
birleşip yani Küreselleşme ve
yerelleşmenin birleşiminden ok
sijen örnekler için mesela internet
bulunana kadar
İngiltere'de
bir hamburger mağaz
aları ve Eee yani o
[Müzik]
titreyle Yemek bize inanılmaz bir
motivasyon
fakat buraya geldikten sonra belli bir
fakat globalizasyon önemini yitirdi
Neden Çünkü internet hayatımıza girdi ve
Aslında internetin hayatımıza
[Müzik]
olduğu ortaya çıktı ve insanların ilgisi
düştü bu sefer Ne yükseldiasyon yani o
ülkenin kültürüne beyinlerini hitap
ürünler nedir bunlar mesela hayatımızda
Kral burgerler girdi o ülkenin kültürüne
damak tadını uygun baharatlarla yapılmış
mimari savunma kültürüne uygun mimaride
yerler
bunlarla başta oldu buradaki
sıkıntı mesela Yurtdışından bir turist
geldi bu yemeği beğenmedi daha sonra
çağırdı genelde dedi cevabı alıyor yani
bu bir yemekte bir şey yok gibi ötesine
geçeyim Allah korusun bir gıda
zehirlenmesi yaşadınız bütün hastane
masraf
ları komple karşınıza karşılar var tabii
ki hayır O zaman ben günümüzde neye
ihtiyacı olarak satış öncesi
ve satımda güçlü bir markaya ihtiyacı
var yani kule var mı markaya ama yoga
ihtiyaçlarıma cevap vermez yani bu
Blokları izolasyonlar versin Ee bu da
bir
Ee İngilizce çalışkanlıklar tarzı bir
şey bu halde Marketing ve bunu da bu
zamana kadar sunabilen hiçbir marka
dünyada yer almadı işte bu noktada
Yağmur devreye girdi kalbur nedir
kalçanın marketinin yani kültürel
pazarlama kısaltmasıdır Ben bir tool ve
bir model geliştirdim şimdi olan durumda
bu zamana kadar dünyada cevaplanamayan
üç önemli soruya cevap
verdim akademik ve özel sektörde
akademik Akad
Emik yüzden fazla ülkede pazarlamak için
ve üropanızı kaybetmeden her gün ülke
için yapacağınız Logar adaptasyonları
sınırı nedir böyle bir model akademik
dünyada yoktu
bunun neden önemli
şunlardan dolayı özel
sektör yıl bir ülkeye gidilir oranın ele
tutuyorsun yani her türlü bir
rahatsızlığını var ve ülke sorumluluğu
farklı olarak fark etmeyen
milleti hitap etme bize genelde bu tarz
ürünler tutar İşte o zaman eleştiriler
tüketici beğenilerinize göre kendi
ülkenizde eğitsel tasarımcımız da bazı
ama en sonunda da bizi onaya gönderin
Tamam denir
Yunus birer aidati'yi koruyabilir
ama günün sonunda
adeta tamircisi mandalina'ya dönüşüyor
ve tüm
dünyayı yeniden bağımsız ve ürünler de
olabilir işte bu aslında lokalizasyon
adaptasyon ile bunu dünyada başarabilen
o dev Mark
Ada bu zamana kadar ben bu odaya
mantarlarda çalıştığım
için şimdi size işte tamam abi bunu
nasıl Başar
dın
Türkiye'de çok fazla arama başarılı bir
pazarlama müdürünü
aldınız yine Hindistan'a İngiltere'ye
Japonya'ya koyuyoruz Sizce aynı başarıyı
yakalayabilir mi cevap veriyorum
yakalayamaz neye ihtiyacı var yıllara
ihtiyacı var Tıpkı üniversiteden
insan
[Müzik]
seçimlerine hakim olmamız lazım deneyim
sahibi yine bu konuda bir aydınlatıcı
notları olarak hayal edil
di olarak
3 cevap
Ona yeni ürünler nasıl çıkıyor piyasa
biraz size ondan
bahsediyor ilk önce Market gibi
krebimizden
marka ekibi filtrelemesinden geçen daha
sonra pazarlama müdürünün
kendisine sunulan 50 farklı
dan ticari araştırmasına sokarım ama ilk
başta 500 farklı alternatif çalış
IR Bunlar süzgeçten geçe geçe Pazarlama
direktöründe
neden 5 yıl
onlar soru sor
uyorsun bazı iyileştirmeler hep
[Müzik]
Fakat ben size diyorum ki Pazar nedir
olacak
tasarım 95'i içindeyse Şimdi ne olacak
ki sizden hissetme bırakıyorsunuz
yani işte bu noktada kalmıyor
akademik makalede yer alarak kabul gören
kalır bunlarda yer aldı Akad
Emik Ana Bilim Dalı başkanlarının
Bu model nasıl çalışılıyor ilk başta Siz
pazarlama karması diye bir şey
var pazarlama demedi ürün fiyat satış
yeri lokasyon ve promosyon şekli buna
karar vermeniz için
araştırma yaparsınız
Her ülke için maalesef uygun değil yani
o yüzden işte Bir ülkede çok Tutal
diyor Başka ülk
ede hiç nedeni de
bu çok kültür bazı Allahtan
sonra
benzer kültürel davranışlar sergiley
enlerin kendi içinde gruplayarak mesela
[Müzik]
Eylül pazarlama kararsızlığından
oluyor çizgi altı çizgi
bütün pazarlama faaliyetlerini Buna göre
adeta bizim
burada işliyor ve
çizikler kapıda
yeni şeyler
Almanya'da ise millet
e yöneldim
yüksek statotik insanla
düşük yani yöneticiler bürokratlarla alt
sınıfın tükettiği ürünler farklı
[Müzik]
bireysel
lik olayların düşükken Kolektif
gücü demek tüketimde Türkiye'de ben
kolek
tif ailemin arkadaşlarını
söylerse bireysel
münferitli
[Müzik]
bunu
Almanya'da
Yüksekova
bir soru formumuzda 30.000 kişilik katıl
dı ülkenize
[Müzik]
şeklinde
dünyadaki en büyük kültür araştırmasını
yapan Profesör Doktor
endeks
leri Bu da demek oluyor ki
Benim öyle bir his
[Müzik]
ve kalıcı ürünler olsun o zaman bu
kısadan
tamamında Kim mesela
onu da bu ürünü kullanmıyor etkisini de
o alan
ının ağırlığı
deneme
e Bilim davranış
larımızın
topluluk ve halimiz arkadaşlar
şimdi tuvalete
[Müzik]
duyguları hitap etme abi bu ürünü
seçimlerinde ve bu ürün tükettiğinde
mutlu olacaksın
meslek mansurana
kıyafet markası tamamında
ve o araştırmamızda bile
soğuk kaza söylemleri
ömrünün ve olağan arasında odaklı
özgürlük olarak ben yeni fikirler açığım
ve topluluğum sisteme göre bir
sanat adamları da her şeyi Açıklıyor
Avrupa ülkelerinde
ise nasıl
tüketiyor
özgürlük olarak olan tasarım
ların hepsi özgürlük oda bağlantılarında
kahve bardakları üzerinde nasıl peki bu
cereyan etmiş özgürlük olan
eğlence daha
fazla takımıyla yapılmış bir tasarım
görüyorsunuz orada bir evde ise Zorlu
tüf
[Müzik]
ek ne kadar
yüksek belirsizlik düşük belirtisi
var Bunlar neyi temsil
ediyor güvenmek ilk planda eğlence
ikinci planda
yani şerefsiz
likte bunlar
la
ilgili otomatikman
mesajları geri planda ikinci planda
eğlence geliyor ve kahramanlık
[Müzik]
eğlenceli işim yok Ama öbür türlü kahve
ile
ilgileniyorum tamamen eğlence odaklı
uçak ve çat
lasın ve
globalizasyon
u zaman sonrasında diğer yüzleri
istisnalar veriyor
ama dediğim gibi Uzunlar akademik seviy
ede yüksek eğitimde düşük eğitim
den kullanabilirsiniz yanlış anlaşılma
vesaire
veya diyetisyeni giderken geniş kapıdan
giriyorsun Sonra aslında
bunlar yüksek eğitimlerde yapılan
mesajlar Türkiye
'deki gibi markalar falan
yok Meydan yok sıcaktır dikkat et diyor
bir espr
başarımız bu şekildeydi araştırmaya
gidiyoruz Türk kahve mat
larını Cover model bundan sonra yolunda
gloped
izasyondan vermeye devam edecektir kanlı
bu model ticari bir model değildir
akademik bir modeldir bu zamana kadar
bütün çalışmaları akademik
olmuş yani
din
lediğiniz için iletişim
[Müzik]
[Alkış]